finissons avec les masques puisque votre
livre s'appelle qu'ovide le bal masqué
les masques dieu sait on en a parlé du
temps où on n'en avait pas on disait que
ce n'était pas utile maintenant qu'on en
a on dit qu'il faut les garder toute la
journée quand on sort on sait très bien
aujourd'hui que le virus se transmet en
intérieur pas tellement voire jamais en
extérieur par les fameuses
microgouttelettes par les aérosols donc
en intérieur et en extérieur et pourtant
on continue de nous obliger à sortir
avec le masque toute la journée
tout ça n'est t'il pas complètement
inutiles est ce qu'on n'est pas devenu
et vous le décrivez bien d'ailleurs dans
votre livre on est devenu au fond des
hygiénistes mais au delà du nécessaire
ce qu'on peut dire sur le masque
aujourd'hui comme quoi il faut faire
attention parce qu'ils transportent la
maladie donc il faut faire attention
quand on l'enlève et c'est ce qu'on
disait au début au début on savait pas
trop maintenant c'est plus nécessaires
ils ne transportent pas plus de germes
que nos vêtements et de toute façon on
sait que le le corps d'un virus ne se
transmet pas par les objets ou quasiment
jamais c'est quasiment impossible
alors qu'on l'a craint beaucoup ont
nettoyé nos courses mais maintenant
c'est que la peine est ce qu'il faudrait
pas qu'on évolue un peu on a
l'impression qu'on n'est pas à la pointe
de la connaissance dans notre pays et
que voilà on continue alors là on va
rouvrir enfin les terrasses mais en fait
elle pourrait être ouverte depuis un bon
moment déjà des terrasses c'est pas sur
les terrasses que ça se passe parce que
c'est pas en extérieur que ça se passe
oui alors c'est un très très bon point
je pense que des historiens retraceront
cette histoire des aérosols et de la
lutte
étonnante d'un certain nombre de
médecins et de d'infectiologie vis-à-vis
de la voie de transmission par aérosol
mais c'est pas quelque chose de nouveau
la tuberculose a été pendant très
longtemps considérée comme une maladie
qui se transmettaient aussi par les
mains par transmission directe alors
qu'on sait aujourd'hui qu'elle se
transmet quasiment exclusivement par
aérosol et je pense que
on aura à peu près la même conclusion
pour ce coronavirus
[Musique]